it is my honor and great pleasure to
introduce mr. Birrell representative
vice president that is going to deliver
speak a keynote speech on the second day
in the new function so we are really
honored to have you with us today thank
you very much thank you thank you very
much for for being late but I had to
abandon the car and coming walking it
was the traffic you know in this crazy
City
I thought the traffic was only crazy in
New York and Bombay but I see that in
Brussels it's also difficult oh well
thank you for inviting me I'm very happy
to participate on your work it's true
it's my second day in office yesterday
it was the first one I had the
opportunity of participating in the
opening of the Climate Change Conference
the COP 25 in Madrid
immediately after going to Paris for the
morning of the French soldiers killed in
Mali and this is my third activity as
you can see is a civil right menu what a
sad day yesterday because the morning of
this French show there was a ceremony
that show us that this shot is where I
killed defending not only the France
security but also the European
securities in countries where to talk
about human rights is to talk about
something and existing today we are
going to talk about it and I am very
happy to have this opportunity because
when I went to the hitting I bought that
human right would be an important part
of the
foreign policy of the European Union and
today we talk about human rights you
have to talk on the perspective also of
the environmental issues normally when
we talk about human rights we think
about a dictator who puts people in jail
and but now we have to deal with human
right and a brother in a broader scope
and the consequences of climate change
it's also a threat to human rights all
over the role because human rights and
environmental challenges closely into
link and affect people on their
fundamental rights all over the world
and not only talking about indigenous
people in the Amazon whose life hoods
are on the theory of threat also about
it but extreme weather events all over
the world are affecting an increasing
number of people globally and mainly the
most vulnerable in society European
citizens are very much aware that one of
the biggest challenges we face are
climate change but it's not affecting us
for the perspective of human right
geopolitically by the contrary it's true
when they affect the conditions of
living of millions of people talking
about Sahel people who will be obliged
to abandon their land because their land
is no longer able to produce for Mayra
cultural point of view it will become
migrants and they will come to Ebro and
this is a special circle that affects
them the human rights both as people who
are obliged to leave their countries and
also later as migrants coming to ask
Silla
maybe the idea of a syllable seekers by
climate reasons it is starting to emerge
I am asking for protection not because
at home there is a bloody dictator who
will kill me but just because I cannot
live and I have to go away in order to
look for security that's why it's so
important that the European Commission
has start working on this European Green
Deal that we will be approving I hope on
the next week's and this will make
European Union big political agent as a
listener as a spender as a provider of
investment capital at home and abroad as
a standard setter in general as a global
actor and at the upcoming European
Council in a couple of weeks the heads
of state and government should finalize
our guidance in order for us Europeans
union to set up a long term strategy on
climate change and this will require a
strong engagement from international
partners and civil society international
partners because we are we rupee UNS
just eight nine percent of the co2
emissions and even if by miracle
tomorrow we stop producing a single
kilogram of co2 but the problem would
still be the same because the still will
be the 92 percent which are being
produced out of the gwelf the european
countries and this puts a strong problem
of social justice all over the world
Global justice now how can we ask people
that has never seen a bubble an electric
bubble that development has to be
constrained due to the fact that there
is no room in the atmosphere for more
co2 emissions there is about 1,000
million people who has never seen an
electric bubble not to say about
refrigerators heaters cars everything
that we have at home and we use as part
of a way of living this is going to put
a big problem of justice to whom the
most fear belongs and who is authorized
to use it and storage of co2 yes we are
not producing a lot but in the past we
have produced too much and the problem
comes from the fact that in the past we
the affluent part of the world we have
been used this public good which is the
amount of the atmosphere the amount that
the atmosphere is able to stock all
these gases so we have to pursue climate
changes inspired and strong injustice
basis and this is why it is very much
related with human right but we can go
closer to real life things and to talk
about the people in the civil society
that worked on the protection of human
rights and fight for a safe clean
healthy and sustainable environment
elemental human rights defenders they
are environmental human rights defenders
I know some of them in my past
activities are true champions working on
the ground often in the face of great
adversity on personal cost and we should
continue to do everything we can in
order to protect them and to ensure them
that they can be working in safe and
enable environment free construction and
insecurity today land and natural
resources management is one of the most
critical challenges the world is facing
land and natural resources management I
will look at the forestation and many
other phenomenon is one of the most
critical challenges that you have to
face and that's why we have agreements
and we have Forrest law enforcement
governments and trade voluntary
partnership in addressing the problem of
land rights and national level and it is
very critical we are doing something to
support it above 40 countries at least
at what this paper says in 40 countries
we are spending about 240 million euros
to protect the human rights fighters in
front environment challenges and when I
am not talking just about indigenous
people who are in the collective
imagination of the worst and
civilization the ones who are fighting
being the guardians of the environment
we know them but they are much much more
risk than many people who are being
involved on this kind of fights
suffering from intimidation harassment
detention and even losing their life and
I can say some examples recently in
Natron America one of the most well
known human rights offenders from the
environmental side who was killed in
undo - Berta Caceres maybe some of you
have heard about her I am happy to know
that some days ago a court sentence for
men to 50 years in prison for the murder
of Verta in my previous life I had to
answer many questions in the Spanish
Parliament asking me what are you going
to do
to protect the family of Berta what are
you going to do in order to ask for
justice for the people who kill birthday
which is a good example of how people
like her coming from the ground from the
indigenous population have become
defenders of human rights from the point
of view of environment I think this is a
new dimension the human rights in
defending and what I can tell you and I
don't want to be longer is that we have
to introduce this dimension on the human
rights fight in 2018 we have listed
three hundred three hundred and twenty
one human rights defenders that we had
targeted and kill for their work the
highest number on record so far it's
quite a big number 321 human rights
defenders from the environmental
perspective more than three-quarters of
those we're just fighting on
environmental issues and since 2015
European Union have been supporting
30,000 human rights defenders that's not
bad that's not enough but to help and to
support 30,000 people all over the world
which were engaged on defending human
rights from environmental perspective I
think it's something that we should put
into value and we have done that through
the European instrument for democracy
and human rights and I hope that the new
financial perspective this budgetary
line will increase because we really
needed
because the problems of you can write an
environment will go increasing in the
next future
I don't want here to become here to
preach and to say that the European
Union is the solution for everything I
don't want to express my happiness
because we do a lot we prefer to say
that we are not doing enough that we are
doing things but not enough certainly
not and whatever we do and whatever we
are able to perform on facing this
problem will be much more effective if
we work together if we work the
ministrations and the civil society the
civil servants and ordinary people who
are engaging through the work of the
oranges all over the world by many ways
enable enabling access to information
supporting land governance we have
signed some agreements with more than 40
countries addressing violations of human
rights by companies and corporate
entities and all of you have in mind
examples of where and how this happens
it doesn't happen mainly in the European
geography thanks God we are over past is
a stage of development but it happens in
many countries with which we have trade
agreements and I think that tricks kind
of trade agreements can be used as a
powerful tool in order to get an answer
from these countries in order to face
these problems how the products has been
produced where the products has been
produced which is environmental and you
right cost of the things that we consume
more and more it's an answer that has to
come from civil society to post the
political organizations in order to take
care of this issue it is not a pressure
from the civil society if there is no
pressure from people like you at the end
on the negotiation table these kinds of
things tend to be forgetten tend to be
taking place of a more important and
pressing economic interest so I know
very well when who you are negotiating
you have to take into account many
different things the more power the more
political power is behind one objective
the more you pay attention to it others
which are much more important from a
human point of view they don't have a
defender behind them you must play this
role and that wider European Union in
particular the European Union external
Action Service would be very happy if we
can work together and to contribute to a
better defense of the human rights
defenders on the field of environmental
we are going to have a lot of work
because and yesterday in Madrid a
listener a lot of nice speeches
everybody claiming how important it is
to fight against climate change and
protect the rights of nature we are in
fight against the nature we have to make
peace with nature that's good the only
thing is that all that has a cost and
someone has to pay it and one of the
most important things that we will have
an effect we have to face it the futures
who is going to pay for it I am always
saying that for people like me it's
quite easy to think about what you're
going to happen in the next 20 years and
to be worried by the end of the world
that will happen 20 years from now but
there are many poor people that cannot
afford
to be afraid or worried what is going to
happen 20 years from now there are too
much worried about about the next 20
days in order to ask them to be worried
about the end of the world the end of
the month is much more important for
them at the end of the that words matter
of social justice at a global scale and
I thank you for your engagement and to
work in order to make the ecological
transition fair because if it is not
fair
he will not happen thank you
[Applause]